Well,
hello and thanks for joining us today on
the broadcast.
Today's episode is sponsored by
candidate.
Should I keep up with it now,
Dan,
even getting a note from Dan,
today's video is sponsored by candid for
Hims Quip and 23 and me now.
Today we have with us bill wirtz,
a musician,
video producer,
youtuber.
What artists are mean?
Artists,
most certainly.
How else is there any classification?
I missed a person person.
Let's not forget that.
Species.
Animal.
Yeah.
How are you doing,
Greg?
Great.
Having,
you know,
Jesus.
Thank you.
So thank you for having me.
Thanks for.
Thank you.
How was the uh,
how is it here in la?
It rained,
which is a typical,
I suppose.
I think it's kind of funny because it
never rains in la.
And your logo is the umbrella here.
You come to Los Angeles and we brought
the rain with you,
which in La is a miracle,
I would say.
Yeah.
So you are a miraculous young man who
was very,
very nice of you.
Yeah.
Um,
our.
Tell me about,
I want to know about a.
okay,
well your first hit,
your first big hit was the penthouse
where you're,
where you're looking in your timeline of
working.
What,
what were your first year?
People were like,
oh,
what's going on with bill works?
Well,
it's all relative,
but here's the thing.
It was like nobody,
nobody,
nothing until the going a million.
My floor got about 200 likes very
quickly on vine,
which 200 compared to zero is like,
that's like what's happening,
right?
Yeah.
So,
but after that it was um,
school on fine,
I don't want to go to school and it was
shaving my piano and then it was a bench
and then,
I dunno.
Do you know how people first found you
online?
Well,
yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I can tell you the first,
uh,
the first person,
the first person who did it was a guy
named Jack Doris Guitar Player,
uh,
his,
he had a vine called,
um,
back back pain or pain back or something
like that.
But yeah,
he was,
he was a big fan and he just sort of,
he just sorta,
you know,
gave me a thing,
know the thing that's amazing that he
just found you in the nether.
Well he found me on twitter,
so,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
yeah,
no,
but that was good.
That was good.
Uh,
and then,
and then more people did it and it was
all from that first 200 likes,
kind of like a steady climb.
Yeah,
I was Kinda like,
yeah,
I'd like to think that it was inevitable
because your style is so unique and
everything about like your editing and
your,
you have such a refined,
specific style,
so unique to you.
I think it was inevitable destiny.
It's very much that's very kind of,
you know,
metal that.
I mean that's,
that was the strategy.
I was doing it for a long,
long time,
just like,
I don't care.
How long were you doing it before
anybody noticed?
Well,
I started the five day schedule in early
2014,
which was basically where I just snapped
because before that it was like I wanted
to do a million things and thought I
could do anything but didn't know how to
put it together.
But finally somewhere along the line I
just snapped and I just said,
okay,
we're doing five days a week video every
day.
He said,
I'm just going to grind.
I don't know what.
I don't know how to figure out how to
put all this stuff in my mind,
so I'm just going to force myself to
work,
work.
Yeah.
And unfortunately they have to be very
short if you do one every single day.
So why did you decide to.
What did you think the vine was the
right medium?
Well,
that wasn't until.
I didn't even know about vine yet.
I was doing it on the website,
actually just the website for the first
month.
They'll works.com.
And then,
um,
someone told me,
a friend said,
oh,
you're making videos,
why don't you put them on Youtube?
And I say I,
I like,
I like it when it's,
when you get the file and you can just
watch the file,
like I don't really like streaming
actually because I like to be able to
pause it and horse it around and really
see what you're dealing with.
So.
So yeah,
I didn't really like youtube but,
but he was like,
well you know,
you got to be on youtube so okay.
So I did you to boot.
So which is a pretty cool but I don't
know him well.
But you had your break on mine.
That was probably,
yeah,
it was where things started and you were
posting simultaneously to youtube and
vine at the trick was I had already gone
down to two week on youtube and then I
discovered vine and I was like,
that would be,
would be great because you can't go
longer so no one can be mad at,
you know,
so.
And they loop.
So the best way to watch short videos
anyways to see him over and over again.
But I figured so I put them there.
I started putting them all there in
order and I had to do a little bit of
editing to square them and in some cases
edit them down to six from,
in some cases,
20 seconds down to six.
And that was kinda fun.
But uh,
yeah,
I put it in there and I wasn't even
going to touch them.
And then I was doing twitter too,
so I had decent following on twitter.
Someone,
someone found me,
like I said it was,
it was someone found me there and then.
And then.
Yeah.
And so do you think that that has.
So for this amount of time you're
craning on vine doing a video five times
a week.
Do you feel like that was like a really
important creative time in your life?
Yeah,
well unfortunately I was desperate to
stop as soon as,
as soon as it got going on,
fine,
because I already had like at that point
I was doing two a week on youtube and
then as soon as I discovered the vines
started to do its thing,
I was like,
okay,
well I got all of these on hand because
I wasn't done uploading them all.
So then I said okay,
I'm just going to.
Well hold on.
You had a back log?
Yes,
because I had,
because it was like a year after year
and a half after I'd started them five
days a week that I started on vine.
So you are grant the microwave?
Yeah.
So,
so you were grinding and grinding and
private and you had this incredible
backlog of content.
They wasn't private.
It was on youtube.
Okay.
And it was on the website,
but it hadn't reached a mass audience.
So you were like,
man,
I've got like a whole library of content
and you were getting followers before
you even were forced to make new stuff
on vine,
but you were editing it down.
Right?
So I was.
Yeah.
So I figured I have these on hand,
so I would edit them and release them
one a day,
so it was easy enough because I was
doing two new ones and seven days a week
I just figured since I have them I'll do
7:00
PM every single day.
So and then I was like,
okay,
according to my calculations in two
months I'm going to run out of content
and I'm going to have to make a
decision.
I'm going to have to either put the vine
thing down to two a week or accelerate
everything to seven a week,
which was even more than I was doing
before.
And this was after I was so sick of
doing short videos,
I could just cry and I was already
thinking about doing much,
much bigger things.
I was thinking about history at that
point,
but.
But now I'm stuck doing seven,
seven short videos a week.
And how important was it for you to have
a schedule to really stick to it?
Oh,
it's,
it's life or death really?
Because if,
because if you don't,
you'll drown because you can do.
It's infinite.
You could spend infinite time then
something.
So wait,
you're saying the schedule helps you
escape the work or focused on the work.
It helps you.
It helps the thing get done.
Yeah,
because uh,
because when we started we also for some
reason had this idea that we got to post
a video a week and we were so strict on
that and I don't even know where he came
from.
We just had this,
you mean back in the day?
I think it was just a personal thing.
It was like a,
it's what kept me motivated and kept
because like you said,
you can focus forever on something.
You at a certain point got to cut for so
many reasons why I love the speed and
the schedule.
So many reasons.
It's life or death.
Well that's not true because some of
them were done without a schedule and
they need it to be.
But when I'm off schedule,
I get obsessed with schedules and I
start watching behind the scenes a
seinfeld documentaries behind the scenes
and all of that.
Have you seen the south park one six
days to air?
I had a while ago.
That's just incredible.
I even get addicted to like how stressed
out they get.
I'm just like,
no,
not that.
That's good.
You romanticize that little I.
Well,
yeah.
I mean I am.
Whenever I'm not on a schedule,
I get so obsessed with being on a
schedule because it goes on forever.
You can't.
Especially.
I mean if you're a perfectionist,
I mean I'm kind of a raging
perfectionist so you know there's there.
Yeah,
it'll go on forever.
What was that quite?
You've said you're a perfectionist and
that sparked in me comment that Ila
thought that she thought was wonderful
and I was struck question because we
have a question thread that we put on
our separated people to submit questions
for you and there was a question there.
That was my favorite and it was how did
you kill perfectionism?
Well,
yeah,
you can use a steam roller or a
bulldozer.
It becomes incredibly important to do
that when you have it as badly as I do
from.
You're never going to get anywhere
unless you have a serious strategy for
steam rolling right over professional.
So you start to do,
there's one called a Monday good fire
truck,
which is like,
that's probably,
I think I hit the mark the best in terms
of flattening perfectionism,
just like,
just just mash it.
That satisfies you when you smash your
perfection is if it means you can get
something done instead of if not.
Yeah.
And after you create a work,
do you look back and see like,
oh,
I could have done this different or that
different or that's in the past and it's
time to move forward?
No,
no.
Done.
And you're happy?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't look interesting and so scary.
The schedule defeats the perfectionism
when you hit your schedule,
that's it.
Well,
it doesn't impede the perfectionism,
but it,
it,
it's like a tool to rags you along.
Yeah.
You know,
you get beat up and cut,
but you get there and you get stronger.
Oh my God.
The thing,
speaking of which the vine,
when I ran out of vines had to do them
fast and then I was doing,
um,
started doing a history of Japan and so
I flipped my schedule around and I
started doing a history first in the
earlier in the day and then just wait
until the last two hours to do,
to do the,
to do the vine.
It was crazy.
I had some crazy times and I was,
you know,
I learned so many new tricks and
techniques that I never would have
learned if I didn't have to,
you know,
crunch down.
Yeah.
Is that because you're most productive
in the morning?
I like your strongest worth because you
said you did the history in the morning
and know the reason for that.
I was trying to get ahead of the
schedule with the,
with the vines.
Um,
but that never works because the
deadline is not there.
So I would spend six hours doing one
even though I thought I was going as
fast as I can,
but I wasn't.
So I just said,
okay,
look,
I need to get this history thing
happening.
Prioritize that as much as you can first
and then about 4:00
or something.
Just run for it and see what you can get
on.
Fine.
You know how many hours a day do you
work?
It sounds you are incredibly productive.
You are incredibly focused on your work.
I can tell by the volume and just in
your website and your work has so much
detail and I mean how much do you do
work and as much as possible how many
hours as possible,
but the problem is I know what you're
going to say.
You're going to say you got to take
breaks and stuff.
I was going to say that.
Well,
most people say that we have as much as
possible,
but the problem is when the problem is
that when you work too much and then it
starts fucking all of a sudden you can't
get out of bed in the morning or if you
have relationships or other things you
want to do that you are,
but if you like what you do and that's
what gets you out of the bed,
then work as much as you got them all.
Please.
Yeah,
well I think I naturally tend to take a
break even though I want to admit it
sometimes,
even if it's time crunched,
crazy time crunch.
Sometimes I'll just go face down into
bed just for 20 minutes just because I
can't even just face down but.
But I can't.
But yeah,
I mean I know it's like,
yeah,
good to take breaks,
but how long should the breakbeat and
how often should the brakes?
B,
you never.
Well,
what are you doing?
He'd say,
well I don't admit it.
I never admitted.
That's the problem.
I had that problem.
My problem is that I'll spend all day
working are all spend all day being
busy,
but then when I look back over the day I
never took a break necessarily.
Like where I'm like to step separate
from my work,
but somehow I was less productive than I
thought I wasn't working the whole day.
I don't know when I took breaks,
I don't know.
I don't have a strategy for that really.
But.
Oh,
but when the.
When things take way too long as it is
and,
and you know,
you,
there's no time to lose,
you know?
So yeah.
I got to make sure.
Do you have hobbies outside of a film
and music?
Luckily I've been able to sort of
incorporate most of them.
I'm trying to incorporate all of them
into,
you know,
like anagrams.
I mean I used to just integrate that
shit is banana.
I have to say I can't believe you.
So bill,
for context on his website,
Bill Wirtz.com.
Is that slash anagrams a no.
A yes.
No,
that's right.
That's right.
Um,
people submit sentences for you to
Anagram and you'll unscramble it and
make a new phrase.
Is that eh?
And some of them are really incredible.
Maybe you can pull some examples up down
that we can read it off.
Real well.
Got.
Some of them are really inappropriate
for,
oh well,
family shout out,
saw the family watching,
but they'll have to endure for some
reason.
It's,
it's very tempting to make them.
Dan sent me something here.
Let's say thank you for your recent
purchase was the submission and bill
turned it into try our corn cake
funhouse therapy.
And then another one,
the joy of painting.
Fight to enjoy pain.
Now,
what?
That is incredible.
That in your mind you can anagram.
No it's not.
It's not in my mind.
You know,
you can use computers now.
Oh,
so you use like a website though,
a computer.
I know people are going to say I'll use
computers.
A computer won't give you that.
Look it along,
like go get a really long uh,
help me out here.
But.
So what?
Well,
what's your technique then?
How do you go?
Jeez,
I don't know if I.
can you.
Oh,
this is the match would never tell you.
No,
but you just gotta to.
Okay,
let's see.
Let's see.
Well if you have these in their need to
find out where the V is going to go
because otherwise it'll turn up leftover
if you have,
you know,
you've got to take care of,
you got to take care of that and then
you just try some stuff.
And then also,
you know,
it's good.
It's good if it relates to the thing,
especially if it's a longer thing,
so if you know,
try to try to think of what words you're
gonna need to relate and just take care
of that.
The long ones are fun because you can
start out saying anything you want
because the letters are going to be
there and then you get down to the idea
like,
oh no,
I have like a surprise,
huge surplus of ends and start over and
try to work some more ins and outs.
And what is it about anagrams that
fascinates you that that's a hobby of
yours?
Yeah.
I started,
I went to my friend's house at one point
long time ago when he was rearranging
scrabble tiles of just doing people's
names and I was just for some reason,
so I just went home and started doing it
and I've been doing it ever since.
Well,
I tend to do like the things that are in
my life,
like if I would get a job I would do the
name of the job or did you know?
And uh,
yeah,
I've just been something I've done for a
long time and finally I was able to
integrate it into the,
into the science.
I definitely noticed in your videos,
in your lyrics are very much kind of
script,
you know,
mixing up words and a lot of wordplay.
Yeah.
Do you,
when you plan your videos,
do you plan out like how meticulously do
plan out and how much is it?
I know you've like remix jazz and you're
kind of a fan of or,
or you have where you remixed gas,
right?
Oh I,
there's a lot of like Coltrane and
stuff.
Yeah,
it's just like jam jam sessions.
It's like,
it's like when it's like the way,
I mean jazz in that sense.
It's like when a bunch of guys get
together and read standards like out of
the real book.
So what happens to be,
except it's just me.
So what I mean is how much of it is
improvised because it's,
it seems somewhat random but very
controlled.
So when you're making a video,
do you make up anything as you go or do
mit or is it completely planned out?
And then you execute the visual would be
kind of as I go along,
but in terms of what,
in terms of the audience,
in terms of the words melodies,
the exact chords and the timing of all
the,
anything that's spoken or sung and the
exact chords in the exact timing is all
written.
If that's written,
everything else is just usually implied
from there.
And then I just fill in the space and
the underscoring.
Sorry,
sorry to the underscoring music.
So the extra little instrumental stuff
that goes in between when I'm speaking,
that's all done after of that.
Makes sense to,
to sort of support.
And so you,
you do the music first,
it sounds like the built around,
not that music,
but the,
the,
anything that's sung or spoken?
I do that first.
The underscoring music is done after.
Interesting.
We've had a long one here.
Back to the anagrams here.
Where does this start?
Okay.
Super Sonic game.
Mega percussion.
Where does it start?
Cringe Poland's USS as long.
It's not long.
That's a short one for horizontal value
that.
That one I had.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Come on,
step it up.
Here's a law.
If anyone's wondering if anyone's just
wondering the answer to that point along
his group is gruesome panics,
use more spacing.
It's escapism.
You're gone.
So you have choices.
Some of them I do.
So here we go.
Here's a long one.
I hope doing these anagrams provide you
with an intellectual challenge.
That's the submission and here's bill's
answer.
Guide me now as I get lunch,
pray to religions and escape the hot
lava and hell,
that's it.
That's incredible that you untangle
that.
Yeah.
I think once you start,
once you start doing them,
you'll,
you'll see a pattern.
Well,
no it's not,
it's just you just start to find stuff.
If you have a high standard,
you know,
you just have to just look and you know,
once you start to get ones that are like
that good,
then you start to like really get
excited.
Is there anything interesting in the
fact that like this,
there's a whole sentence with the
alternative meaning in that original
one,
is there something that fascinates you
about just which one?
Like you're writing a whole new thought
just from the original one.
Yeah.
I wonder if that's a thread somehow
throughout your work.
I Dunno.
Let's Anagram that I can't do it right
now.
I'm so history of Japan when that came
out.
That was an incredible,
incredible explosion.
Yeah,
so popular.
Yeah.
I mean right now I think it has 43
million views,
but.
But that's now.
I mean I think it had something like
just in the first week at like over 10
million views or something or even more.
Maybe it was,
yeah,
probably about 10 maybe after a couple
of weeks.
So surely.
You were just blown away by it.
Yeah,
because I was so tired of being stuck on
a vine stuck under seven seconds.
Like I said,
I was desperate to.
I was like,
if only I could do this,
I'm so in a way was a react because this
was a really epic undertaking and this
was a reaction to being like,
I hate doing the small stuff.
I want to do a huge.
I didn't hate it.
I loved it.
And when I would sit down to write a
bunch of new ones,
I got really excited every time button
I've,
yeah,
I really wanted to do something the same
thing.
So tell me how long did it take you to
create that video?
Fourteen weeks.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Because on Youtube people do not.
People spend one day,
but it paid off in 14 weeks.
My God.
Tell me,
how did you do you don't want to know
how long history of the world took.
I do want to um,
um,
how did you decide on Japan?
Are you a fan of Japanese culture in any
way?
But I,
I'm not an expert really.
I mean I was during for temporarily,
but I did.
I wrote one for the United States much
earlier because I wanted to do that.
So you'll have this grip for us.
Never,
never got finished.
But um,
and it was going really well,
but it kind of,
you know,
I'd never done this before so I didn't
really know it was kind of falling apart
because it kind of,
I knew too much about certain things.
And so yeah,
that didn't happen.
But then,
so when I came around to try it again,
I said I got to pick something that I
don't really know about interests so
that I can just learn about it from
beginning to end and then just spit it
out so it won't be,
you know,
just as a challenge because if I can do
that then I can do anything.
So that was the idea.
There's almost a nice quality too,
I think in the end,
the output when you don't know anything,
like you said,
you know,
suit so much about USA.
It kind of muddles I,
yeah,
I know too much about some aspects of
not enough.
Yeah.
And um,
what is your research procedure like
because you know so much about so many
things,
like all these little details,
it seems so well researched and you've
got timelines,
characters.
How do you,
how do you lay that out?
I don't entirely remember actually.
I mean I did it very fast.
It took a long time to make the video,
but I was scrambling.
So how much time on research alone,
I can tell you that research and writing
was kind of together because I would
just learn a bunch of stuff and then
write just.
Right.
I think that was about a week.
I have the timeline.
I posted the timeline somewhere.
So yeah,
something like that.
Writing and research was about a week.
And are you re your.
I was always.
I'm wondering,
do you find people like nitpicking your
facts?
Of course.
Does that bother you or you're just like
and whatever?
Uh,
yeah.
No.
Yes and no.
I don't know.
Yes,
I did the best I could,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
And it is entertaining actually.
I'm surprised at how few people do that.
Okay.
So that's your views and so many people.
I mean I was really careful.
I mean I'm obsessed with like
geographical,
um,
accuracy.
Like I saw Japan video that I was
watching like to learn stuff and they
had Kyoto really in the wrong place.
It was a cartoon drawing and I was like,
I know I'm just,
I'm kind of obsessed with with that
while it showed,
it's when I watched that you're like,
this is a guy that knows what he's
talking about.
It kind of has that vibe.
So.
But when you present yourself in that
way,
there's always people who are looking to
like find one thing to nitpick,
you know,
I probably spend too long on those
things where I put the stars on the,
on the,
on the cities,
you know,
I remember,
I remember actually there was an early.
I haven't seen that since it came out by
the way,
but I think there's an early point where
I'm showing where all the old,
like clans are or the old.
So you haven't watched the video?
I've not seen it since it came out.
Why flashbacks?
Flashbacks?
Of what?
Just the just.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't watch videos after I make.
I try no exception unless someone like
forces me to,
if I see it by accident,
but what I was going to say is,
yeah,
I probably spend too long on those ones
with the stars.
Now when you say that you're like,
you're kind of like that one was a
millimeter like that one was.
That one was difficult because it's like
ancient clans and stuff like that are
ancient ancient locations.
Like one of them is called Hai Hai.
How do you google that?
Yeah,
took a long time and there was one for
history of the world where I showed like
a million cities and I spent a long time
getting the exact coordinates all for
like half a second on screen,
so I don't know what's wrong with me,
but.
Well,
you know,
whatever.
And I think something's great.
Yeah,
thank you.
Got It all backward.
I find it interesting that you don't
watch that video back.
I,
I love it so much.
That video is amazing.
It's amazing.
It's got to feel good help.
Almost prolific.
That video was how it kind of
reverberated through culture.
It wasn't just youtube,
it was on reddit.
It was online,
it was everywhere.
It was on television.
I mean everybody does.
You see it on regular television.
I must have.
I don't know,
maybe it was.
I don't know.
I don't think it was.
I think people,
the way I remember it was people were
watching it.
I remember Black Joe Rogan was watching
it and talking about it.
It just was so prolific and it's
influence.
I mean,
that's the mark of this insane quality
that you brought to it that nobody
really.
None of your contemporaries are really
doing.
And I see you smiling.
There was too kind,
too kind.
Well,
I think it's amazing.
I think you're incredible.
I think you're a gift.
Oh Geez.
Um,
I love that part by the way.
when the nuke.
Oh,
Dan just founded on CNN.
Bill,
what's up now?
CNN doesn't count.
Is it on CNN?
We have a clip on there.
One of their youtube channel.
Check it out later.
Oh,
he doesn't want to launch.
CNN must've covered it at some point.
I don't know where it's on television,
baby.
I love this moment.
My favorite moment with the Hiroshima.
He does this for those of you who
haven't seen it,
I mean mostly I'm sure all of you have
history of Japan.
When the US drops the bomb on Japan and
the video is very manic,
super fast paced.
It's very dense and then all the sudden
the bottom drops and it's just like.
Yeah,
and another one and it just gets quiet
for a long time because of the manic
nature of the video.
It makes that moment so powerful.
It's been a long time getting that
sound.
I'm layering windy sound and the huge
bass sound.
Just really feel that explosion.
A lot of layers in that.
It's like a drum and then it's pitch
pitch way down now.
Was there you.
You nailed that so beautifully.
Did you read,
was there something in your research
like that informed that when you were
just,
you felt the gravity of that?
I know that I don't,
obviously it's heavy,
but like I feel like there was a real
expression there,
a real empathy there.
From what I heard,
they dropped a bomb and destroy it a
couple of like entire cities,
so that's,
that's a big deal.
That's a big.
Yeah.
That is a big deal.
Well,
I love that.
And then you.
You touched on it again in history of
the world in a really beautiful way to.
What was it?
They did a game.
The game show thing.
It's fun because I got to hit the same.
It's kind of like back to the future to
hit some of the same things,
but do it a little bit differently.
Yeah.
Actually the most fun part was doing.
We'd like the video game soundtrack
music for,
for that,
for that section.
You play video games.
There's no time anymore.
No time became a play.
Now is the one game where I make videos
so I.
that's fun.
Yeah.
I guess if more people thought about
life as a video game that might be more
productive.
That's a shower thought while we're on
our first break.
When we come back I have,
I want to talk about so much more
incredible.
Bill Wirtz the incredible talent to
apologize.
I'm terrible at doing interviews.
I'm sorry.
Now I really.
I so,
I mean this is.
I don't get out first interview.
Oh God,
yeah.
Of this sort?
Yeah.
Well first,
let me say that trusting us with that
experience of you coming here,
it means a lot to me.
I appreciate that and I think you're
doing great and I'm fascinated by
everything you're saying.
So let's go to a quick break.
We will be back after this with Bill
Wirtz.
They'll go away.
Here's a product that I wish I had when
I was a kid.
Candid.
Okay.
They make these incredible invisible
braces that you order out.
They measure your teeth,
they send it to you at home.
They go on,
they look clear.
You can't even tell you're wearing
braces and it fixes your fricking teeth.
I was walking around with metal in my
mouth and then have ruined your life.
This is so much better.
This is the future candidate.
Have you ever had a problem with your
teeth that you've always wanted to fix?
I've got an option that can help you.
You won't need to go through the hassle
or longterm treatment of wire braces,
Aka life ruining torture,
and you can do it all from the comfort
of your own home.
It's a new company called candidate by
the way,
you can pop them out and in to like when
you're eating,
I mean this is so much better.
Candida makes clear aligners that are
sent directly to your home and are
customized specifically for you to
straighten your teeth.
By the way,
this is what they look like.
Ben,
I don't know if you show on the screen
the aligners fit crooked teeth,
crowding,
protrusion and gaps.
The first step is to purchase their
modeling kit,
which will be sent to your home so you
can take impressions of your teeth.
And,
uh,
after you send back your impressions
with some photos of your teeth,
candids networks of orthodontists review
your specific case and provide you with
the three d preview of what your
treatment will look like.
We're having a real orthodontist is the
main reason you're going to love
candidate because other companies use
dental professionals.
Whatever the heck that means,
am I right?
They wrote that.
I don't know.
After you received your red preview,
it's completely up to you.
If you want to move forward with your
clear aligning treatment plan or not,
and you can always talk to a real person
at any time if you have any questions.
They have great customer support.
White Glove,
they said whatever that means.
White gloves,
their customer support.
Whereas white gloves,
you guys if that's good for you or not.
I don't know.
I prefer without gloves personally and
here's the best part.
Candidates,
treatment time is an average of six
months.
I think I had mine for like two years.
I had mine for six months.
Oh well you know you're ruining the
coffee six months and will literally
save you thousands compared to the other
guy I did have mine for like two years.
So you're one step away from getting
straight in whiter teeth.
I did.
They white,
I guess they and them too.
I don't know that.
Take advantage of candidates.
Risk-Free modeling kit,
guarantee plus when you use my dedicated
link,
candid code.com/h
three,
you'll save 25 percent on the modeling
kit.
That's candid code.com/hp
to get 25 percent off the price of your
modeling kit.
Candid [inaudible] dot com slash h
three.
Listen Up.
You Bald headed goofs.
All right,
this one's for you.
If your hair's falling out,
if you're in the shower,
you see that cycle your air going down
the drain.
Listen,
66 percent of men lose their hair by age
35.
The thing is,
when you start noticing your hair's
going,
it's already too late.
It's a way easier to keep the hair,
that beautiful hair that you've got on
your head than it is to replace the hair
that you've already lost.
Okay?
I know that hairline is slowly moving
backwards like the,
like the,
uh,
setting tied like a low tide that never
comes back in.
You got bald spots.
How do you feel a year from now when
it's busy,
when it's business as usual up there,
I asked you,
let's get rid of those bald spots.
Let's do something about it.
Let's get that.
That receding a ocean line to come back
in.
The tide comes back in.
Yeah,
let's get a tsunami on your head for
hibbs.com,
a one stop shop for hair loss,
skincare and sexual wellness for men.
Thanks to science,
thanks to science baldness is optional.
Hems,
connection with real doctors and medical
grade solutions to treat your hair loss,
we got well known generic generic
equivalent to the name brand
prescriptions to help you keep your
hair.
Okay guys,
this is prescription solutions backed by
science.
There's no waiting room,
no awkward in person doctor visits.
You're going to save hours by going to
[inaudible] dot com and you're gonna.
Keep that beautiful,
luscious head of here and be the God
that you are.
Answer a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and prescribes you
the products that you need directly to
your door.
So listen up or to right now my
listeners,
you get a trial of a month trial of
hymns for just five fricking dollars
today,
right now while supplies last.
So see the website for full details.
This will cost you hundreds of dollars
and so much time if you went to a doctor
of pharmacy,
so go to for him.com/
[inaudible].
That's f a r h a,
m s.com/
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible].
When you think of the perfect gift,
you probably don't think of an electric
toothbrush,
but guess what?
You should because quip is one of the
most gift guided gifts of the season and
this is why.
Okay,
they've got a sonic vibration,
gentle enough on your sensitive gums and
built in timer with guiding pulses to
remind you when to switch sides to make
sure you get that throat toothbrush that
you need.
Quip is the gift that keeps refreshing.
Brush heads automatically are delivered
on a dentist recommended schedule of
every three months just for $5 and you
can even get a gift prepaid refill for a
year to make sure that they never get
old,
worn out or in affective bristles.
Quip is one of the first electric
toothbrush excepted by the dental
association,
and that's thousands of five star rated
reviews.
I love quip because it's just.
It's so convenient.
It's so tight.
I get the quality of a much more
expensive electric toothbrush.
You know,
dentist say electric is the best way to
brush.
Boom,
boom.
It tells you exactly what you need and
your mouth is going to thank you for
just try this sweet little baby.
That's why I love quit.
Looks like it's a big ticket,
big ticket tech gift,
but it starts at just $25.
So go to [inaudible] dot com slash
agency right now and get your first
refill pack for free with a quick little
quip electric toothbrush.
But you don't have to tell your gift to
that.
Oh,
uh,
that's your first refill.
Pack free at [inaudible],
g e t e q u I p.com/h
three now through a now through
December,
25th,
now through December 25th.
The APP now through December 25th,
the 23 and me Dna kits are on sale.
Twenty three me helps you understand
what your dna can tell you about you and
your family story.
It's named for the 23 pairs of
chromosomes that make up our DNA.
Twenty three and me DNA kit is the
perfect gift for anyone you love and
there's never been a better way to give
the gift of genetic discovery.
Your parents,
siblings,
aunts or grandparents.
And everyone else on your list is the
one gift that you combine the entire
family and it will be unique for every
loved one.
You got the 23 and me health and
ancestry service,
which includes 90 plus personalized
genetic reports that offered DNA
insights on what makes you unique.
It's easy to do.
All you do is spit in a tube,
which is the fun and sexy as part of
your day.
And 23 and me.
Kit Registers your sample to your
personal 23andme account.
In a few weeks you'll receive your
personalized on our report.
Here are some of the things that you can
discover just a couple from analyzing
your DNA.
Do you like the taste of Cilantro?
I've heard people say that it tastes
soapy,
which I found was blew me away because I
love Cilantro and Mexican food.
Apparently that's genetic.
You can find out if you have an aversion
to Cilantro.
How about this?
Your ability to match musical pitches,
genetical you can see and their DNA.
How about this one?
Uh,
my cell phone?
Yeah.
They say that right?
Everyone hates noises like nails on a
chalkboard.
But for some people,
the reaction can incite rage or panic.
That's something mosquito bites.
How frequently do you get bit by
mosquitoes?
This always and so much more.
You can find out from this report report
just from spitting out a little tube and
send it off in the mail.
Now through December 25th,
get 30 percent off any 23 and me kit or
do your DNA kit at 23andme.com/hie.
That's a number two or three a and d
meet.com/
[inaudible].
Again,
23andme.com/h
three.
Welcome back everybody here with Bill
Wirtz.
I want to ask you about history of the
world I guess.
But before that I am curious to ask you
about.
You have this very unique aesthetic
style and to me as a video editor
myself,
I am captivated by your editing style.
It's incredible.
Um,
how did,
where did you,
how did you develop that style?
I don't know,
I,
I'm just trying to get,
you know,
be reasonable really.
I mean I'm just trying to do it,
do what needs to be done,
you know,
get the job done.
And unfortunately it's the only way I
can do it really.
And some people say everything looks too
much the same,
which I don't know how I'm gonna avoid
that because you know what,
how is that the only way you can get it
done?
Because it seems like there's a lot of
effort that goes into the visual
quality.
Like you've got this kind of neon
psychedelic and it's like multilayer.
Well you know the are huge,
right?
You do all the art and the videos are a
lot of most developments.
Clip art.
Right,
right,
right.
Which is kind of.
Well I got a graphics thing when doing
history of the world because I wrote all
this stuff about space and stars and
then you're gonna have earth.
Like what are you going to do?
So I got kind of graphics tablet,
so that's cool.
Yeah,
that's helpful.
Too Bad.
I can't really,
you know,
a long way to go there.
But.
No,
no,
it's great.
I mean it's great.
It's very specific style.
But do what,
what do you edit and can I ask that just
as a,
I'm,
I'm a curious editor myself.
Well,
I'll give you a hint,
it's,
I'm screwed and a lot of a lot of people
are in or we're,
I don't know if anyone's stayed screwed
for this long.
If you were to.
Yeah,
there was a popular program that was
industry standard.
I know long time at a certain.
Yeah,
at a certain point they made another one
with the same name,
but it's,
oops,
it's a different program.
So.
And I'm sure it's fine.
Most people hated it.
X Ten,
whatever.
Most people hated it when it came out.
Then they bad mouth my trusted is going
to be okay because the other option is
the one that you have to pay every month
and it's like,
I can't do that.
I don't want to do so.
Um,
so yeah,
I trust that it's gonna be okay,
I'm going to switch,
but there's never a good time to relearn
everything.
I know every week I learned a new thing
on the thing that I'm using and I've
had.
I mean,
if you want to know what it looked like,
go back to the first Monday video on the
five day schedule.
I think it was about a Pelican or
something and it's nothing.
It's like text and nothing.
Well,
the truth is,
I mean you are using what was considered
industry standard.
It's not even that.
It is the light light version of that.
Oh,
it's missing.
I don't know what,
but I've never seen it.
So I don't know what I mean.
You got eight stuff.
Oh yeah.
The truth is,
uh,
I'm looking forward to switching but
because like we added put me here and
um,
I feel like with every upgrade they've
actually added some stuff that are.
So sometimes they'll just break the
software and that was a true.
Are saving so much time.
Let's say a new mask.
And do you know anything about final cut
10?
Yeah,
I know I used final cut but not 10.
So that's the new one you have to pay
for?
Or is that the one that uses x?
X is the one that x is what replaced.
So which is what you're talking about.
I've literally only met one person ever
that liked X.
everybody else.
But we'll see.
I've heard,
I've heard the same rumors,
but I have found at least two or three
people that say,
yes,
it's fine,
don't worry.
It's getting better.
They say they're adding back all the
things and it's like the one I have is
not even the one that you think I have.
It's worth so you can do.
You can do it on anything as long as you
spend time with it and that's one of the
reasons I don't like to go around saying
what program it is going to know.
People are just eager to buy a thing and
they think they're going to get a
billboard that's a,
that's an emulator.
They won't get that.
That and that's true of kind of any art
craft.
If you have like a sick guitar or an
amazing computer or whatever is the tool
that you use,
you have to master your craft and here's
another thing that helps.
If you get really crazy software before
you know how to use it,
will it will ruin you and it.
I mean I've been,
I've been there,
I've done that and.
And you get frozen for for years,
you just don't even touch the thing
because you don't know what to do.
So intimidating and not intuitive.
Those,
these programs are not intuitive at all.
Well,
they might be,
but it takes time to learn.
It's like a language,
you know?
Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah,
I think that's good.
That's good advice for people who are
trying to learn things is just get in
there and do that first and then worry
about the tools and just got to you.
I just,
you gotta use simpler tools.
I mean you got to just use what you have
used,
what's available and you know,
you'll go really far and then by the
time you're ready to,
you know,
then one by one step by step you can get
an upgrade.
But the.
So did you develop this visual aesthetic
with the title fonts that you use and
all that?
Is that something that you just started
with or is that something you developed?
I'm just trying to get by.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does develop over time if you want to
see what it was.
I mean,
you know,
go back to Monday,
Pelicans or whatever the heck that was,
nothing.
And then gradually just a little bit
more.
And then when I started doing vines
everyday really fast,
it kind of accelerated.
I mean,
I just started learning all kinds of
stuff.
That's cool.
Um,
so let me ask you still learning stuff.
I mean now I'm on a really tight
schedule and I'm learning more and more
and more.
All good.
I'm learning so much about editing.
I was,
I did what you said not to do and it was
to my detriment because I learned how to
edit on premier,
which is like the industry standard on
pcs and you when you don't know what
you're doing and you don't know the
right tools,
it's,
you're so freaking slow and it's taken
so long to catch up.
Like I was working with an editor we had
hired just a couple of months ago.
Alex,
sweet kid,
great kid.
I don't want to call him a kid that's
like,
he's a sweetheart.
He's a great kid.
Um,
and he taught me like a couple of little
key shortcuts that like changed my life.
Like it's literally saves me hands up
ours.
Yeah.
I have this crazy thing.
I mean there's a lot of.
And the thing I use,
there's a lot of things that don't,
don't have shortcuts that drives me
crazy.
But there's a trick,
I use a on a Mac,
if you could command question mark opens
up the help menu and then you can type
the first two or three letters of what
you need.
So it's like eight strokes but I do it
anyway.
Oh,
you got to shortcut the shortcut.
Yeah,
I mean I have all this.
Like I said,
that's why I'm going to be so screwed if
I have to switch because it's like I
keep finding new little tricks and
inventing new tricks.
Or do you,
when you edit,
are you on the laptop or a computer or
laptop and to use a mouse?
No.
Oh my God.
I had a feeling,
you know,
I had one of those nights,
I had one of those nice trackpads on the
side,
but the um,
the batteries like leaked and it got the
door that the battery door got stuck
that a usual,
I could not get it open and it was,
it was like leaking acid and then I
couldn't get the thing I have,
I cannot edit on a laptop,
you know,
I met a man without a mouse.
I mean the thought of that is
unbelievable and it's a testament to
your genius and dedication.
But I will say if I were a genius,
I'd probably get something better.
But again,
the problem is we're all screwed because
if you go to system higher than whatever
the one high Sierra was the one where it
officially stopped working.
So what?
The,
the program doesn't work anymore and the
new computers.
So you're limited.
But I'm going to.
Well,
I'll say this,
you run.
I knew a kid.
You may not know anything I'm talking
about,
but it reminds me of this for all of you
who have ever played world of warcraft
or serious video game.
Do you play video games?
We'll work craft.
Do you know about any of this stuff?
I don't have time to do anything except
make.
Unfortunately it was a very intense
video game that's played with a mouse
and a keyboard and I have a friend who
clocked thousands of hours,
was in the highest level of rating of
collaborating with 40 plus people,
high level raids and I played with him a
lot.
I was good friends with him and one day
I went to his house and I saw this kid
on a laptop without a mouse and I didn't
know it was possible to do that and I
was absolutely blown away.
He was playing a high level game with a
trackpad on a keyboard.
It blew me away and I thought this man
is a.
he's incredible and I have this.
I have this admiration for you.
To edit without a mouse is truly a feat.
It's probably not smart.
It's probably not smart,
but the desk that anyone who supports me
on Patrion is going to get so mad
because I,
you know,
because I'm not spending money on.
I have a desk that is 10 years old and
cost $10,
probably 10 bucks.
Where'd you get it?
That was it.
Convenience store pharmacies and those
pharmacies.
Now that you,
that you and you bring up an interesting
point,
you are supported primarily through your
Patrion,
is that correct?
No,
it's,
it's a combination of,
of,
of things.
Yeah.
But that's a,
that's a big piece of the puzzle.
So patrion,
by the way,
if you guys want to support bill,
put it in the scripture and
Patrion.com/bill
wirtz,
right?
Yeah.
And I have to apologize for my lack of,
of a social skills in tact and
everything,
but thank you to anyone who has.
I've never,
you know,
my patron is blank is blank and I've
never said,
you know,
it's like really promoted.
No,
no,
but they are helping pay my rent
essentially.
So thank you for that.
Well I think that's fair.
When we were starting off,
we had a patron,
um,
and we also had it blank because I
don't,
I think that's the point,
right?
Because they want you focusing on what
you do and not necessarily trying to
make gifts and not central for people.
I'm not sure that's how I saw it.
I was just like,
thank you for supporting me.
We can continue to do what we do,
which is apparently what you want more
of.
Right.
So I think that's perfectly fine.
I hope so and,
and,
and very reasonable because I didn't
have one and everyone said know,
Geez,
why don't you just at least make one
just so you know.
So,
you know,
so yeah.
But is it true that you turn off ads on
your youtube video?
Not entirely.
I had them off for a long time and then
I realized that if you want to get the
red,
uh,
income from that you have to go the way
they have it.
Wow.
Uncheck every box except for display
ads,
which is the one that puts a picture on
the side.
I still didn't want to do that for a
long time because,
uh,
because when I see ads,
like really when I see them,
it really makes me uncomfortable and
stuff.
So really?
Yeah.
So,
so,
but I have that on there and I know,
you know,
you're going to be mad at me for not a
lot of people are mad at me for not
having the video pre roll video ads on
like the history video,
but I don't.
I figure so.
So you never really had a big payoff
from those big,
big Japan and history of the world did
because through the other things,
the youtube red stuff.
No,
through patron and there's paypal donate
thing.
Oh.
So a lot of people responded at directly
support.
Yeah.
Oh well God blessed.
That's,
I'm really happy to hear that.
I think so yeah.
Thanks to those people who are there.
Um,
I support you on Patrion you just did
this morning.
I good enough at it.
You don't promote it as well.
I figured you were just making money
like the rest of us.
But here you are like working your ass
off and amazing content.
The thing is certain,
I won't even mention the name,
but certain web companies and stuff like
I'm stalking me for the rest of my life
through through targeted ads like
interests and you know,
and it's like I can't even,
I can't put other peoples through that
bother you that people follow you on the
Internet trying to sell you shit.
You have to becoming targeted ads and
it's just really annoying.
It's good strategy.
Even though,
and this might help you be at ease with
putting ads on your videos,
you have an option as a youtube creator
to turn off targeted ad.
That's true.
I don't know if that helps you.
It might because I do want you to
prosper and to make money so I don't
know,
but that is that the primary reason you,
you don't run ads on your videos,
it's just a drag for the pure and plenty
of people always tell me,
no,
it's not.
People are saying,
you know,
no,
it's not.
You know,
they say we don't mind,
but they can't speak for everyone,
some people.
But do you do.
What do you think about the fact that
like everybody on the,
um,
how do you say the expected experience
is that there's an ad there,
you know,
like television or any popular medium
because how,
how are you expected to provide for
yourself?
That's a good point because maybe the
reason I haven't done it,
I'm trying to psychoanalyze this because
I really,
I probably should,
you should,
I,
I think you should.
And so I know what it is.
I remember when there were no ads on
youtube.
I don't know if you remember that,
but youtube is like,
there's no way they can't put ads on
youtube.
It's the Internet ads are for the TV.
And then I remember the first day I saw
an ad on youtube and I felt like the
outrage,
you know,
so I guess it's been a long time since
then,
but I still,
I guess youth that outrage lives.
Yeah.
Even though maybe I shouldn't anymore,
but look,
but look at you,
you are extremely hardworking,
talented,
your life,
your work.
As you say,
I don't have time to do anything else
because I'm working.
So this is not just some dude posting
vlogs are fucking around a hobby.
I mean this is your life,
this is your work.
I mean you're entitled to get paid for
that work.
And,
and in addition to Patrion,
which is completely optional,
if people can support you there.
Oh.
So it was an artist.
You say like your work is your art and
you put it up there for free and you
know,
like other artists sell their work so
you put it out for free.
So at least you could get money that
way.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll turn it on.
Not to impress you.
I say that for most things too,
but it,
it,
it doesn't work that well nowadays
because with the Internet you still have
to one person and then they can send it
to everybody else.
Oh,
you smelled like digital media.
Well it's still music,
but I mean it's also on the streaming
sites.
So there's paid for that I guess.
I guess there's ads there,
so technically there are ads so you
know.
But in the Internet,
you know,
it's like,
it's kind of,
you know,
selling stuff on the Internet is kind of
not entirely real good.
I mean you can sell it to the first
person.
You could charge a billion dollars for
the first one,
but then once one person has it,
they could,
they could just send it to anyone.
Well,
what do you think about what Wu Tang did
had that album that I was thinking that.
I mean that's,
that's.
Yeah,
they did it.
And as far as I know,
nobody's heard that album at Martin
Shkreli.
Still.
That's too bad.
It is too bad to prison.
He can't do anything with it now.
It's probably an evidence been somewhere
in prison.
It list for them.
I had heard that he had played a portion
of it on a stream.
Really.
You know,
I cannot believe that album was sold for
only a million dollars.
It's Wu Tang.
Like how did nobody pay more than that?
Martin Scarelli is the only guy who
willing to shell out a milli for that.
Yeah.
You would think like someone like Jay z
or you know,
someone who's like really Wu Tang
anyway,
I still haven't figured out what it
means,
what it means to sell stuff on the
Internet and what.
No,
because in the old.
Yeah,
I just looked it up and uh,
apparently that album is now in the
hands of the government and they seized
his uncle because I wonder if they ever
imagined their million dollar album
would end up in the hands of the
government of all people.
Maybe they'll add it to the library of
Congress.
Hey,
there you go.
They should.
Sonia.
That's so funny.
So do you,
what do you consider that?
What,
how do you consider that act by Wu Tang
to have this one CD?
Is that cool?
Or is theoretically what I thought was a
legit thing,
but I still have not really figured out
what I think about that.
Because you want people to hear you.
Do you want your work to be seen by as
many people as possible?
Exactly.
So that's why you want to.
Yeah,
it's interesting and strength.
Definitely.
Interesting.
But anyway,
not to persuade you about the ad thing,
I only am looking out for your best
interest and I want you to prosper and I
think you'd be surprised by how much
that can then add to your,
your,
your quality of life for Christ sake.
Yeah,
I might.
I might do it.
I mean,
do you,
do you have any idea how much money
those two videos alone with it?
It'd be a lot of people have deemed me
on twitter.
I mean hundreds of thousands.
Well No.
People have.
I used to get dms on twitter saying
we'll pay you.
I won't tell you how much money,
but we'll pay you this much money for
you to just turn over the rights to the
ads for those big viral hog.
So funny.
Like viral people that wanted to buy the
ads,
right?
I don't know.
Someone.
Someone said we'll give you,
you know,
made a huge hugs and assuming no driver
for,
for just that ad sales.
And have you had like sponsors reach out
to you as well?
Yeah.
Any interesting people come in rolling
through your email.
Interesting opportunities.
Yeah.
Anything interesting that you're working
on?
Things usually the most interesting ones
have these long disclaimers at the end
that says you can't talk about any of
this.
So.
Okay.
No,
I'm not asking.
You don't have to talk about it,
but that's cool to know that you're
cool.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
that's exciting.
I can't wait to find out whatever that
is.
Well I've,
I've said no to a lot of most of them or
save them or.
I mean I'm notoriously bad at
collaboration,
collaboration kind.
So.
Well that's good.
At least I was hoping that people would
have recognized kind of what,
what's going on with you and because I.
well,
what,
what is your,
um,
what is your aspirations?
Are you feel like you've arrived youtube
or what is your dream?
I'm going to take take over the world.
Maybe take over the world.
You want to be the dictator?
No,
no,
no.
I don't wanna do that.
I don't know.
You want to make a movie?
You want to make a cartoon?
You want to make an animated Alva
hopefully something better.
You know,
thing,
figure out what that is,
you know?
Interesting.
Yeah,
I would.
I would freaking die to have like a
history of like that as a show would be
absolutely captivating.
I want to do that to the problem and
that's what I wanted to do.
But the problem is it takes so long to
make you will,
you would work with people.
Is that something?
I know,
I know that would be how to do it.
You could have a team of 20 people.
You can make one every month or I know
you can make a whole 10 marks and
they're already doing it.
We already got a show.
It's just slow.
We don't get an episode every week
about.
Is that okay or would you be happy to
see it accelerate?
Is What?
Okay.
Oh the right now never was.
That's why I.
Yeah.
Well it's been a wrong way.
Ron,
if you could,
what?
What's like the perfect rate of
releasing those in your ideal world
history videos?
Yeah.
Once a week.
Is that enough time to do all the
research?
Here's the problem.
Then I did the entire world just because
I figured let's escalate,
how do we see Japan and after doing that
I don't,
I look,
I'm really interested in history or I
was.
I mean I'm really like really,
you know,
and after doing that,
like I don't want to say another word
about history African.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So you don't want to make the history
series.
I did.
It was the only thing I wanted to do for
a long time and then I did.
I just did the entire world.
Not that I accept everything in that.
In fact that was the most painful part
was because the more you learn,
the more you find out how much you're
going to have to leave out.
It's like 99 percent you have to worry
about and you know.
Yeah.
That was painful.
But I assume so.
Are you not working on a,
another history video right now?
No,
not right now.
No.
I'm doing songs like every.
Is there some longterm project and the
background that you're working on?
No,
but I think there's about to be.
Oh yeah,
because I just got to the.
Yeah,
I think there's about to be,
you found a topic or something that
fascinates you or you don't?
Um,
yeah,
I can't.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
Well I know that every,
everybody loves,
everything you put out is adored,
but those,
those specific works or just like,
I mean they're modern masterpieces and I
think everybody just can't get enough of
that anymore.
Just a masterpiece.
You cannot get people on Youtube.
To what,
how long has the history of the world?
It's like for like 19.
I was hoping it would be five because I
didn't have time to take another three
months off,
you know,
so I was like,
okay,
five years,
five to seven.
And then I was writing,
I was writing it after two months I was
still writing,
not making the video.
I was researching writing after three
months and it's at 12 minutes and it's
like reading at 14.
Yeah,
it's just,
you gotta turn the adds on to.
So how long did it take you?
Total will be 11 months.
Wow.
Yeah,
we're at,
I don't recall.
Were you gone during that whole time?
Just like,
what do you mean?
Were you posting videos?
No,
I was like,
it wasn't done.
But I mean on your youtube channel you
hadn't posted?
No,
there was nothing.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
it was rough.
Every single day you wake up to like
everyone's saying pressure and like gone
from the.
Yeah.
But you came back big time.
Well,
I never left when you posted.
I mean in the end,
the mental collective of the world,
so to speak.
Yeah.
So let's move on to the history of the
world then because that video now if I
see that video,
uh,
the history of the world I guess has 55
million views and sits on our videos
number two of all time with 176,000
up votes.
Do you use reddit?
No,
not really.
But do you understand?
Kind of.
Yeah,
I know what I mean.
How nuts that is.
So when you posted that video,
what was your expectation for the
reception?
Well it was,
I knew Japan did that.
It was number one and read it and all
that stuff.
So I was like,
okay,
this could end.
It's a huge escalation from the Japan
video.
It's like the ultimate thing,
so I was like,
okay,
this could really get there,
but you just can never get it.
You can never.
Which is scary.
I've been working on this for a year
since I was thinking at the end of it I
was like,
I never want to spend this long on a
thing again.
It's scary.
I'm very thankful that it came through
and it,
it,
it did,
it did as well.
So what was that like for you when you
finally.
That must have been such a relief or
relief.
Somebody told me,
somebody texted me and they said it's
number one year.
It's number one thing.
I was just really.
Because I spend that long,
you know,
you don't want.
And Are you happy with how it came out?
That video?
Yeah,
I guess.
I mean I'm,
I haven't watched it since it came out,
so I think it's okay.
There's plenty of things that are just
way under cooked.
I mean look,
it went through like within the first
four months and something that I started
working on the graphics and stuff like
that.
I was,
I mean I must have spent all day looking
for images of different like apes and
stuff like that.
I must have spent all day looking at
apes and finding that perfect clip art.
Yeah.
And then I was like,
what am I doing?
It occurred to me that this is going to
take multiple years to finish if I don't
seriously kick myself faster every day.
So it really just became again and again
and again.
I had to just pick myself up and just go
faster.
That kind of goes back to the whole
issue of deadlines because you're such a
perfectionist.
When you remove that deadline it can
probably drive you crazy.
Yeah,
I mean,
but you know,
I mean around October I set a deadline
of December.
First I was like,
this has got to get somebody.
During October,
November I was kicking ass.
I was like,
dude,
working so fast,
but it came around to December and I
wasn't nearly done and then I just
couldn't get out of bed for a few days.
It was just too much,
by the way.
It didn't get done to me.
What you said you couldn't get out of
bed.
You mean you were just despair.
Just like working so hard.
I was just like,
I needed a break because you're,
you're.
Are you up to the point of like you're
not even sleeping that much there?
I do sleep.
I sleep good sleep.
How much sleep you sleep?
I sleep 10 hours a,
it'll be like nine or 10.
Yeah.
God bless you.
Unless now I'm on a schedule and
unfortunately toward the end of the
schedule it gets ridiculous toward the
deadline.
It gets you set an alarm clock.
No,
God bless you to do.
I know.
I don't know if for me be the one joy
being self employed is not setting an
alarm clock.
I mean that's,
that's all that matters for me.
Problem is I tend to drift telling you
personal things,
but uh,
by sleep schedule drifts forward like an
average,
about an hour a day.
Like on average you would like rotating.
So you sometimes wake up at like 3:00
AM.
Well,
anytime it'll,
it'll,
it'll keep drifting.
If I don't have to,
if I don't have to work for anybody
else,
you know,
it'll,
it'll gradually drift.
So what's your sleep schedule that like
right now?
Right now I woke up early.
You're on the early one,
but I mean I just released the.
Well yeah,
it's,
it's weird.
It's.
I got it.
I got enough sleep though and um,
I find that so interesting.
So
do you find yourself more productive at
a certain time of day or is it all just
rotating?
It's all a blur.
It doesn't matter that much.
What time it is kind of food do you
like?
Oh,
I don't know.
You order.
I would cleared.
Food is weird.
I don't like to talk about food.
You don't like talking about food.
Food is weird,
man.
Not that interferes.
Food is weird.
It is weird.
The whole thing go eating thing.
It's just a weird thing.
No,
it's good.
And we all,
I think we all think we all do it.
We,
I mean certainly that is a requirement.
I have to.
I think I read a book that says we all
do.
We all do it.
It is pretty weird though.
I don't find it.
That's strange.
I love food.
You can tell by looking at me.
I'll eat all day and he was pregnant and
she's.
We can,
we can not talk about food.
I mean I don't have that much to say
about it unfortunately.
That's interesting though.
Isla doesn't really love food,
but she's pregnant now and she's turned
into like a,
I want to say beast mode,
which I love.
I don't.
I mean that is an absolute compliment
because I'm a monster and she hardly
eats so now for the past three nights in
a row,
we've had pizza at midnight last night I
was eating pizza with the and I was
like,
this is the happiest I've ever been.
It really did say that.
I usually each their own.
Yeah.
I usually don't care about pizza,
but you don't have a preference.
You don't like specific foods.
Pizza.
It's okay.
I didn't realize how some reason.
I don't really like to talk about food.
I don't know why he lists that way.
What about,
are you a coffee drinker?
Ice,
ice cold?
I just really don't like to.
I really don't like to talk about
preferences of like what,
okay,
what different people leader or at least
for me sound like to talk about it.
Okay.
So let me.
But I will say that.
Um,
yeah,
hot coffee.
I just can't,
I can't,
it,
it's,
it burns me physically.
You're sensitive to the temperature.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Like,
I dunno,
I just drink it and you're like,
oh no,
I'm burnt.
Doesn't burn.
Like for the few days as well.
My brother's very temperature sensitive.
He kept.
Yeah,
he,
he can't eat like until it's like
lukewarm at a hottest.
Has this explosion in popularity since
these last two videos,
do you get recognized on the street
ever?
Well,
I mean,
uh,
sorry of those,
those big too,
I feel like really put true.
Yeah.
Do you get recognized on the street
ever?
Does that happen to you?
Maybe it does happen sometimes.
And do you um,
has this popularity affected your life
in any way or you feel like everything's
the same?
It's weirdly the same.
Right?
Because before I had it,
I was pretending that I did.
It's just convenient because now I don't
have to change a damn thing.
That's interesting.
When I was posting five times a week on
the website and I had it all like that,
you know,
I didn't even tell anyone that I was
doing that and I was just carrying on,
like pretending that it was really
important and they do have a day job.
What was life like before you were
making money from your art?
Like music stuff,
you know?
Oh,
music stuff like gigs and stuff.
It's various things,
you know.
Cool.
Yeah.
God bless 'em.
I'm just wondering,
have you gone to you seem,
are you classically trained with music?
I sort of know.
Uh,
no,
but I figured out sort of through the
grapevine,
like the names of stuff,
like the names of the notes in the chord
self-trained oh yeah.
Completely.
Really?
Yeah.
And what,
what was your first instrument?
The keyboard?
It was piano and drums and piano.
Back to drums and piano.
Interesting.
Who are your music inspirations?
What kind of music do you like?
Oh God,
I don't know.
But you have a very specific style and
you know,
and you know,
that's,
that's unfortunate because,
you know,
I,
I wish I could,
I'm just trying to do,
do whatever I can,
you know,
it's like if you have a green tractor
and if that's the one you have people
say,
why do you like to drive?
I want to have,
you know.
Do you listen to music though?
Because yeah.
Your whole life.
Is Music Your Music Ira?
It is.
What are you listening to these days?
Unfortunately there's not that much
time.
But you have a favorite artist?
No,
I don't.
I don't break it down like the Beatles.
Well I don't even like really break it
down by artists because it's every
single artist is going to have stuff
that I really love and that I don't
like.
And I think it's that way with everyone.
Maybe it's not even by song,
by Song.
There's parts of the song that I love,
parts of it that I don't even individual
moments of songs.
Wow.
Parts of it that I don't think I can do
and don't it.
So he's funny.
That's funny.
That reminds me of kind of what Jason
Donkey said.
He does this,
this blew me away.
He says he'll take songs that he loves
and cut out the parts he likes and cut
out the part that doesn't like and then
make a cut of his perfect idea.
In that Song I've done that really
changed the billing to a.
I cut up the bridge to pretty woman and
changed it.
Pretty Woman Roy orbison.
Great tune.
For some reason the bridge just it takes
this detour that really bores the hell
out of me.
So I just changed it without adding
anything new.
I just took the meat part and I pitched
it up a whole step and another whole
step and comes back around.
Were you always interested in music or
was that kind of,
you know,
keeps coming back.
I think by the time I was about 10 and I
was just like,
it was just one of those things that
kept coming back.
I was like,
oh,
I better do this then.
Yeah.
Is there,
is there an artist or band or style
where you think like that's like,
what was it?
Was there something you ever heard as a
child or whatever where it was kind of
transformed when you're like,
I want to make music because this is
just so brilliant.
Yeah,
it was probably a bunch of stuff.
I don't remember exactly.
I don't know.
Can you hear those?
There's,
there's sirens outside.
The soundproofing can only do so much.
It was actually a window behind that
foam Paul Desmond sacks plan on,
on take five.
It's a very famous tune.
I mean,
he does a nice job on that.
That's real good.
I mean,
I heard that at a young age.
Feel good.
So that's jazz.
I don't know.
Yeah,
sure.
Dave Brubeck.
There you go.
Um,
people.
Uh,
but yeah,
I know.
I don't know.
That's a weird thing to talk about.
Now people are gonna think.
Well,
I don't know.
It's all good.
You don't?
Nope.
No pressure.
I don't know why I'm so weird.
No,
you don't.
I get the sense you don't like talking
about your musical inspirations.
Well that's not true,
but I'm a little confused about what you
like or what about what you want to say.
Yeah.
I'm not sure.
I haven't figured it out yet,
but one thing that I will always come
back to again and again is popular music
can't get away from it.
Really can't ignore it.
You loved pop music.
I refuse to hate it unconditionally,
which I think it seems like everyone
around is always doing it and I can't.
I,
I will.
I think.
I think that's a wise way because
clearly there's something there that
people find irresistible.
Sure.
At pop music,
you're right.
As,
as always,
from the times of like what I was a kid
like backstreet boys and Brittany Spears
or whatever's popular.
The reaction of everyone is always to be
like everyone was cool.
Yeah.
But then you start finding these
articles and now on youtube,
you know,
you can see interviews from 1955 from
1925 from a,
you know,
for any given year in the past.
Everyone's always trying to say that
nothing's good nowadays and that the
latest technology has ruined everything.
Right?
Once you see how prevalent that
viewpoint is at every single moment in
history,
suddenly you just can't take it
seriously anymore.
You know?
Why would it be true now if it wasn't
true then that's really,
that's a really great option.
So it's just I have,
I have no patience anymore for,
for,
for the pop,
the unconditional pop hate.
Thanks.
That's a great great.
And I'm not saying I like every tune
that's ever on the radio,
but man,
every given your and everyone has
different tastes but any given year if
you just check out the charts,
there's at least a handful of tunes that
are just like here,
you know,
I,
I know and it'll be different ones for
different people and maybe some people
like none of them.
That's fine.
Maybe,
maybe that's true,
but I just think it,
it just never.
It never stops,
you know,
2014,
2000,
one,
19,
52.
I mean sometimes I go to,
there's a charts website where you can
just listen to stuff and you'll hear,
you'll hear good stuff and you'll hear
people that are copying their neighbors,
just trying to sneak in there and that's
always there too.
And that's cool.
I don't know.
I think that's really wise and reminds
me,
the best example of that that I always
hear is like Bob Dylan,
when he switched to electric,
everybody was like,
uh,
it's so poppy and it's not authentic,
and everyone was saying that he was a
hack and it was making pop music because
he switched the electric guitar.
Maybe you could say that about Bob
Dylan.
You can't say that about anyone is,
do have a artist today that you like a
pop artist that you're a fan of.
Can't really.
I can't really,
you don't like naming.
I can't really say,
you know,
there's so many things were and I don't
even pay attention anymore.
Like,
because there's,
there's certain songs where I'm like,
yeah,
I love that song.
And I was.
But I don't even think about whether or
not it happens to be by the same person
of another song that I can't stand.
I just don't even notice anymore.
I don't even.
Interesting.
I don't know.
Um,
I would say when I look at your style,
I will consider to be almost
psychedelic.
Do A.
is that an influence on you at all?
No,
not,
not physically,
no.
But you know what it was.
What do you mean?
Do you take academic?
No,
I've never.
I've never done.
Yeah,
no,
I,
we were talking about this backstage.
You kind of are,
you have this frank Zappa kind of vibe.
I think about you with this,
like really excentric brilliant music
and you,
you may know about for example,
is that he was very much not a drug
user.
He was very sober,
in fact,
to the point of even expelling people
from his band for using drugs and that
was during the sixties and seventies
when,
when everybody was on drugs and I,
he was one of the most eccentric and
creative musicians from that time
period.
Do you,
uh,
relate to that?
But I wouldn't do.
I mean,
I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't kick people off the bat
unless it was like messing up.
Yeah.
You're like,
dude,
you're not good at or not shown up to
the Gig.
Yeah.
Do you play in bands?
Do you play music with other people?
Right now?
I just.
Do,
I just do solo?
Yeah.
Because you're very much a one man band,
as I understand from watching your
videos.
Yeah,
but the.
But the live,
the live show is going to be a band for
sure.
Oh,
we got a live show,
but the thing.
No,
but the thing is it's going to be.
It's going to be a.
It was just going to be a band.
Tell me about this live show.
What's.
What is this?
It's not happening.
It's not happening yet.
But you're planning.
Yeah.
Well No,
I'm not for it yet,
but I'm planning to plan.
You're planning the planet.
Yeah.
It's in the word.
And so I'm very curious about this.
I think a lot of people are.
This is a tour that you want to do.
Well,
like I said,
I'm not planning it,
but I'm planning to planet.
Okay.
So you haven't got that far.
No.
And the problem is,
but while I'm doing it,
I can't make a new any new songs or
videos,
but it can be a lucrative.
Does that to you?
It does money.
Does money motivate you at all?
Well,
it doesn't change.
I hope it doesn't change what I do or
like how I do it.
So.
No,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean I need it.
You need it.
I need some of it.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Are you,
you don't care about being a
millionaire.
I think you just want to keep doing what
you do.
Well,
that'd be convenient.
It'd be nice.
Well,
touring will be very lucrative.
I don't know if you want to do it like
that and putting ads on would also be
very liquid dude.
You would be making it.
I'll do it.
I'm telling you,
you're going to text me and be like,
thank you dude.
I'll have to text the million people,
other,
other people who told you to get started
first.
I think the only one.
But can I take credit for having
convinced you?
Because this I feel like.
No because you didn't convince me.
I'm not going to do it.
I'm just saying that could get you off
my back basically.
Fair enough.
Okay,
fair enough.
That's cool.
It's a good.
Honestly,
it's a smart idea.
I probably should do it.
Well.
Um,
let me see here.
Oh,
you won that.
You won the shorty award?
Yeah.
How was that experience for you?
Because you went up there and just drive
her to thank you and you bounced out.
It was too weird.
What was weird about it?
Well,
it's kind of alarming how bad my social
skills are.
Like when I go to a place like,
it knocked me out.
Like I didn't even expect,
you know,
I went to,
I got invited this vip find party thing
and it was like I walked in and I walked
right out.
You just walked in and did a one.
I did.
It was like at a bar with ping pong and
stuff and it was like a kindergarten
flashback because it felt like the whole
room was already talking and already
knew each other and I'm just like,
wow,
there's never a good time to interrupt
someone and awkward for everyone.
I think socializing,
I think we all need to acknowledge how
weird socializing is.
It's so hard.
Hey,
hey guys,
playing ping pong,
can I get next game?
We've never gone to one of those events
for the same reasons I avoid.
Yeah.
But,
um,
did,
uh,
what,
you're alarmed by how bad your social
skills are.
I'm just surprised because you have like
social anxiety.
No,
no,
it's just I have no,
there's nowhere to anything.
Once I'm in a conversation,
it's cool.
As long as there's something to talk
about.
I was like,
yeah,
it's starting to get that foot in the
door.
Yeah.
So I pretty much had those things.
I just literally get a beer and stand
somewhere in the corner,
just really.
And people approach me because they
recognize me.
So that was convenient.
That's nice.
Very nice.
And tell me about the award ceremony.
Did you ever play ping pong,
by the way?
Did you get a game?
Do you play Ping Pong?
I don't know.
Oh No,
no,
I don't,
you know,
let them go.
It's not that big of a deal.
Yeah,
it's not that hard.
It's not really that big.
We could actually is probably pretty
hard.
It's hard to be good at like forrest
gump.
Good.
That's hard.
Yeah.
Um,
but it's,
but pink box really not that serious.
Um,
how was it accepting the award?
Because I was watching you.
Had you,
you had this great little video you put
I guess on your website,
but you never posted on,
on Youtube.
Maybe it was on vine about you being
like,
I went up and I told her keep the door
open because I'm going to be fast.
That was when I explained pretty much
half of what I just explained actually.
Yeah.
Um,
tell me about that acceptance.
What will you had a strategy where you
planning on that quick thank you.
Yeah,
I,
it was a,
it was an option.
It wasn't authentic,
you know,
because I saw,
like I said,
I saw Andre 3000 doing it at the
grammy's.
He had a very strong effect on me for
some reason,
but it's not,
it's not rocket science and he's not the
first person who's done that.
I'm surprised more people haven't done
that.
Well what more needs to be said.
Probably some more things could have
been said,
but I just didn't,
I just didn't have it and it was just,
you know,
like the ceremony was going on and on
and everyone's like thanking,
thanking their manager's manager and
their social media manager and all this
stuff.
I'd never heard of him.
Okay.
But the detail of that story that I love
was that you're walking up to the stage
to accept the award and you and there's
a girl who's got her arm on the door
that you are planning in your head
ahead.
You says,
I don't want to be awkwardly waiting for
her to open the door for me.
So he says to her as he's going to his,
he says,
I'll be quick.
So keep the door.
I wanted her to be,
to have the door right here.
That was pretty slick.
I love the that we can see your thing.
Right.
And the footage that was you show,
you'd be like that door now.
Where was that something you were
planning while you were in the audience
being like,
if I win,
I don't want to be standing there
awkwardly.
A brooding over this I,
yeah,
I,
I know I was going to do as soon as I
walked into the theater,
I knew I was going to just because I was
all the way in the back to this is we're
just talking about how,
you know,
antisocial and basically that's okay.
Okay.
I,
I find it charming.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's genuine.
Um,
I,
I am very,
hey,
feel like I have social anxiety.
I feel like I need to draw stuff.
I saw Al Williams interview where he was
just like doodling stuff while he was
interviewing because I just couldn't
deal with it.
He's like,
he was like,
thank you for interviewing me.
I know I need to do interviews and it's
totally cool,
but just forgive me.
I just have to just A.
Do you feel that way?
Is that,
do you want something to draw?
No.
Do you feel that way?
And that's like you don't want to do
interviews but you feel like at some
point you have to.
Yeah,
probably.
Yeah.
Is this confronting and kind of like a,
I don't know if it's a fear but like a
necessity of you being here?
Yeah.
Well it's fun to,
you know,
so cool.
I mean I love,
I love having the opportunity to speak
to your logo is the umbrella.
What's the significance of that?
Well this is what happened really.
I was doing,
I didn't on my website,
I had no logo,
I didn't really want one.
So,
but then I was setting up the youtube
channel and so was setting up the
banner,
so had the black background and it says
hi,
I think it still says to this day said
hi or something.
So that was cool.
And then,
and then the,
the,
there's a thing in the corner where the,
there's a thing you have to put in the
corner.
So I was like okay,
well you got to put something there.
So I just,
I just put,
I did it based on what was already
there.
So the high thing there.
So yeah,
I just picked what would look good and
then I realized that that's actually
gonna be the thing that shows up as my
thing,
which was a surprise to me.
I didn't know.
I just thought it was something was
going to go in the corner.
But you're happy with the umbrella?
Yeah,
it's okay.
And I try to use a different color when
I go to each different platform.
Um,
do you have pet peeves or things that
annoy you and pee,
Pee,
pee?
No,
I,
uh,
I dunno probably do,
but I can't think of them right now.
Uh,
what keeps you up at night?
Um,
I dunno.
Geez.
I don't know.
I don't have answers to these.
What gives you the most hope in the
world?
This is,
you have a list.
Don't twist Sanya whole list.
Yeah,
I have a list.
Well,
when I was doing the history of the
world research,
I sort of,
I already knew this,
but I sort sort of solidified in my mind
even more was like the way progress and
discovery and things getting crazier
happens all the time.
You know,
like it was just rocks for like billions
of years and then something more
interesting and that it was for a long
time and then then something gets
discovered and then like,
you know,
so and that's been happening forever and
faster and faster.
But do you think about the future in
regards to that stuff?
Are you interested in like robotics and
computer science and space and all that
stuff?
Yeah,
it's probably going to get really crazy,
really fast.
Are you a fan of Elon Musk?
Do you follow all that space x stuff and
Tesla?
I think he's pretty cool,
but I understand there's some,
I dunno.
Yeah,
Do you?
I love him.
I love Elon Musk.
I love Elon Musk because I feel like
he's a.
here's a guy who is fabulously rich.
He is one of the richest people in the
world and he uses his wealth and his
influence and his intellect,
in my opinion,
for the betterment of mankind,
and he and he has to do in a way that's
profitable obviously,
because how can you,
but space x,
which is basically just fueling his
fantasy of starting a colony on Mars,
nearly bankrupted him as did Tesla.
The guy's been on the verge of
bankruptcy from gambling.
Everything.
He's got his billions is vast wealth on
these insane ideas that everybody said
was impossible.
Having a private company that sends a
rockets and outer space,
who would ever do that except the
government,
uh,
making electric cars,
zero gas with batteries,
efficient enough to take you through.
And German people said that was
impossible.
I love him.
He's incredible.
Love Him.
He's pretty cool.
I don't know enough to really.
He's amazing.
But I,
I'm fascinated by the rapid increase in
Texas.
I didn't even know.
I didn't even really.
I feel like I didn't really explain what
I was trying to say.
You said what?
What am I hope that gives you hope?
Yeah,
I don't know.
I have it,
but I don't know where it comes from.
Oh,
you.
You feel like you're a naturally
optimistic?
Hell yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
God,
I wish I had that.
I feel like I'm painfully centered,
cynical.
Do you think I'm painfully cynical?
You know,
not all the time.
Thank God.
But you feel like you wake up generally
have a sunny disposition.
You're happy.
No,
no.
I've been worse morning.
Anyone does.
I have morning anxiety I think.
Yeah.
No,
I have crazy morning anxiety.
So what does that mean?
Morning anxiety when you wake up and
you'd have crazy anxiety just because of
like,
of,
of what?
What are you anxious about or is it just
a general feeling?
So this show this morning.
Well I don't blame you for that.
I mean it's a new experience for you,
like what you have to do that day,
things like that.
I just.
Yeah,
I think so.
And when you have that eye opener,
you know [inaudible].
Yeah.
I don't know.
I want you to get into your work.
You feel more comfortable?
Yeah.
Once I figured out what I'm doing and
it's cool.
I feel like that's most people.
It might be,
I almost wouldn't trust someone who
would tell me they just wake up happy
and so pink.
Yeah.
Oh,
thank God I'm alive.
That's kind of how you should be.
Right.
That somehow we're not maybe think,
God,
what a day of wonder.
That's like all those self help gurus
are like every morning I'm blessed that
I'm away.
I think if you really care about doing
really good stuff and good work and
really care about making stuff good,
there's to be a flip side of the coin
because you're going to get really
paranoid that it's not going to kind of
have to a little bit and hopefully it
doesn't kill you.
You know what I mean?
It doesn't kill you.
Do you believe in Ufos or ghosts or do
you subscribe to any.
What would be considered as conspiracy
theories?
Ghosts?
You know,
I thought ghosts were pretty cool and I
looked into some things.
I found like some lists of all the most
famous ghost sightings and stuff.
I was kinda disappointed.
Most of them were not very believable.
I thought I was going to find some
really believable stuff.
I've heard some stories from people I
know that are very believable,
so I agree.
Whenever I look into the ghost stuff
because I am,
I'm happy to accept a naturally
skeptical person,
but I agree with the.
The evidence is not compelling yet as of
yet.
I thought I was.
I was expecting to find it,
but I didn't use it yet.
What about Ufos and aliens?
Do you think aliens are out there?
Well,
I think alien just means someone from a
different planet than yours.
So I think depending on which planet
you're on,
the other person would be.
Do you think there's interplanetary
beings that.
Do you think there's things on other
planets?
Of course.
And do you think they visited the earth?
I don't know about that.
Maybe they have,
but the thing is no,
I don't know.
You think there's intelligent cultural
beings out in the universe?
Yeah,
there would have to be,
but.
But here's the thing though,
where we're going.
How long have we been?
How long have we been here?
Really like zero time.
This is one of the things I was talking
about,
things that are like going super fast,
like we're here and we're,
I mean I don't know what the future is.
We'll either maybe be extinct or maybe
we'll invent an entire way out of this
entire paradigm somehow or,
or invent our way off of this planet or
something.
I mean like,
so the chances that I don't know what
I'm trying to say.
The chances that there's another,
like that word,
the only one what,
what,
what you're.
Or what I think is that the chances that
we're the only ones here cooking on this
planet.
It's like lower than the chances that
there's other intelligent cultural
beings on other planets.
I would think they would have to be,
but there might to be right.
It might be pretty quick.
It might be pretty temporary and pretty
quick before they like,
well,
what fascinates me about our time on
earth is that it took a while to cook us
up like and on earth has been around for
a long time and the dinosaurs were cool.
They were dealt but they weren't really
going anywhere with science and shit
like that.
So the media was like,
alright,
you know,
hard,
reset that let's throw out the leftovers
and start over and so I wonder how many
hard resets before you get someone that
can build a spaceship or build a
computer or something,
you know?
Yeah.
Didn't take that many.
Only like to,
for us to come pop out of there too.
There was like a several mass
extinctions.
Right,
right.
There were like five.
So five resets it took.
Yeah.
Huh.
I'm sorry I'm not more of an expert so I
feel like I'm letting you down.
You're not letting me down.
Um,
I think I was an expert while I was
making the history of the worldview.
There's new stuff in your head now.
Yeah.
I think Elan Musk believes were living
in a,
an,
a,
a simulation of what he thinks that we
are living in a computer simulation of
something else entirely.
That reality is just a computer
simulation
of
I guess.
I guess that would mean that someone
else's control,
someone else is controlling it for some
reason.
Like if you think of like,
okay,
whatever.
Yeah.
All right.
Well I'm excited for your live show your
concert.
That's for there isn't there?
Isn't one yet.
I'm excited about the idea for the idea
that you're entertaining.
The idea is ecstatic to me.
I really want to do it now.
The problem is that I can't make videos
at the same time,
so I don't know how I'm going to say.
Well,
if you guys want to help out a bill
words,
if you want to help support him and his
work,
please head on over to Patrion.com/bill
words like as a description,
I'll ask because you won't.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you that you want everybody
support bill.
He is a gem.
Um,
and I thank you so much for joining us.
Oh Jeez.
Thank you for having me.
It was an honor and a privilege and a
pleasure.
Likewise.
So guys,
I hope you had a laugh.
He'll be at a giggle opiod were
fascinated as I was.
Um,
why do we have next week?
Uh,
it's not a 100,
100 percent confirmed,
but it's a big one.
If it does work out,
I don't know,
should we,
should we say that?
I think,
I think it is.
I think it's pretty much plant.
I think it's happening.
Jack Black.
Very exciting.
Big Fan.
Crazy.
And it's cut and kyle's coming on as
well as it just yet.
Uh,
I think it's just Jack.
I don't think kyle is available maybe at
an unusual time.
Right.
Well we'll figure it out.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll make a twitter post.
Might be at early one.
Yeah,
right in the morning and it sounded like
that's the only time I work out,
but yeah,
that looks like it's happening.
So we'll see you.
I will see you,
uh,
I think an unusual time next week,
but we'll keep you guys posted on the
twitter account.
And once again,
is there anything else you want to,
uh,
talk about a million things but I can't
remember them.
A belt works on Youtube.
Bill Wirtz everywhere except not bill
works on social media because you can't
get the work well on instagram and on
and on.
Not the words.
Yeah,
that's a great one.
Alright guys.
Well,
have a blessed weekend.
Enjoy.
Enjoy being alive and when you wake up
tomorrow morning.
Thank God off miles.
All smiles,
baby.
Alright guys.
Thank you so much for watching.
Have a blessed weekend.
See you next week.
Thank you.